alors oui daniel darc elle pour moi car
le bel album que j'ai jamais fait ouais
j'en suis persuadé ouais ouais c'est à
ya eu à un moment où effectivement je
venais un petit peu du punk et à et
c'était important pour enfin j'étais
dans je voulais un petit peu choqué les
choses comme ça maintenant sujet passé
ça et je faire des belles chansons et ea
j'ai fait ce que je voulais et je
continue à faire ce que je voulais on
verra plus tard mais pour le moment
c'est parfait quoi parle problème avec
vous je pense c'est que à l'époque vous
avez eu un énorme succès avec taxi girl
qui était un groupe un peu saintais
kraftwerk un comme ça un peu électro pop
quoi alors alors que vous en faites vous
êtes un vrai rock'n'roll heroes avec ce
que ça comporte de taille adage de
vaines
c'est la grande force d'injection
d'héroïne oui ouais un peu comme iggy
pop disons le succès que vous avez eue
c'est avec un groupe un peu clean
c'était un malentendu
mais je les accepte complètement
maintenant je veux dire ok alors voilà
vous étiez au sommet avec taxi girl
et puis votre rencontre avec l'héroïne
s'est passé un petit peu comme dans un
comme dans un film quoi vous ayez au
rose bonbon la fameuse boîte de l'époque
et puis un jour il ya un mec qui arrive
comme ça et qui vous dit quelqu'un veut
quelque chose
ouais ouais moi j'ai moi je moi je suis
vraiment j'ai appris récemment je
pensais être timide mais on a dit
récemment que j'étais fabrique sociale
donc ça me mettait parce que les
interviews tout ça je pouvais pas
répondre
j'étais complètement bloquer quoi et
puis et puis je me souviens très bien on
m'a mis une aiguille dans le bras
j'étais en train de vomir a déjà je me
suis dit ça y est j'ai trouvé avec j'ai
trouvé ma raison de vivre
voilà donc il a fallu du temps après
pour que je comprenne que
il n'y avait pas que ça et puis et puis
comme aurait été la chambre plus fort
que ça est bon en plus la première fois
c'est gratuit donc la première chasse à
l'intrus qui est bon et ça monsieur lune
de miel
c'est génial je dirais c'est évident que
personne ne prendrait de l'héroïne si
c'était mauvais mais comme je dis
toujours au début on en prend pour être
bien apprendre en prendre au palais pour
marc est mal bien sûr pour vous ça a
duré 15 ans comme l'histoire way une
quinzaine d'années et puis grave soit 5
g par jour c'est beaucoup comme un goy
ce soit cinq points de plus ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'était beaucoup c et d
j'entendais guillaume depardieu qui a
fait 6 9 heures dos
moi j'ai dû faire ça en six mois quoi ça
j'ai fait vingt verdoso - roche et je
compte plus c'est le conte est bon qu'on
ne fait pas violence et mère pour vous
en sortir la mer va vachement et des
voix alors vous dit en parlant de ça
d'ailleurs quand on a une overdose c'est
pas du tout le white flash dont on parle
d'un agent sandro canal ccd claque de
pompiers dans la gueule c'est pas si
drôle que ça va cesser c'est horrible
c'est horrible un verre d'eau ce
vraiment c'est tout c'est dégueulasse il
n'y a rien de bon là dedans c'est ce qui
a détruit taxi girl parce que déjà
pierre wolson
il en est mort lui il est mort d'une
overdose et puis les autres
laurent stéphane ils sont partis à cause
de ça stefana le bassiste a repris des
études de maintenant ils astronomes et
laurent ouais bien sûr et des partis au
vietnam pour décrocher mais bon c'est
pas le meilleur endroit c'est peut-être
pas naît à la fin vous vous retrouver à
deux coups avec une héroïne your way et
c'est à mon avis c'est ce qu'on a fait
de mieux
enfin la musique allemand quand il y
avait juste l'ignorer c'est moi c'est ce
crocs vraiment c'était ce qui avait mis
un album énorme produit avec burnel qui
s'appelle seppuku qui sait tout coup
un album génial merveille s'il s'en est
sorti alors lui extraordinairement bien
puisque maintenant il fait toutes les
chansons de madonna
ouais et produit il fait les chansons de
ma nana mais il lemire est complètement
parce qu'il s'est enfermé dans un studio
pendant cinq ans
dix heures par jour il travaillait je
trouve ça génial je suis très content
alors à part votre mère qu'est ce qui
vous a permis de vous en sortir de la
dope
moi je n'aurais pas qu'on puisse arrêter
la dope pour quelqu'un d'autre pour même
si c'est la femme qu'on aime ou quoi que
ce soit ce système pas ça s'est fait
comme ça on arrête parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on moi moi moi moi mon truc
depuis le début c'est quand même écrire
et je pouvais plus écrire musique
s'invite ça m'a sûrement aidé à écrire
des trucs en fait à 99 % des cas où je
te l'avais dit la veille
jésus vous a aidé dieu m'a aidé voilà le
berns et parfois achetés directement et
glover v ouais bouzid le christianisme
et le rock'n'roll sont les dernières
forme d'honnêteté
ouah je pense je le pense sincèrement
alors au départ vous êtes juif par votre
père catholique par votre mère déjà pas
facile alors pendant la guerre votre
grand mère paternelle
madame rose zoom est morte à auschwitz
où la belle à mardi noir les montages
suite a été attaché ensuite un look
super est obligé de se cacher évidemment
en normandie
mon grand père aussi et la libération
votre mère a été poursuivi pour
intelligence avec l'ennemi en fait elle
est tombée amoureuse d'un médecin de la
wehrmacht qui était pas du tout nazis
qui étaient là qui était en france qui
étaient obligés parce que son ca
d'ailleurs il a fini en sibérie parce
qu'il était prêt il était pas nazi et
voilà elle est tombée amoureuse
alors on peut prendre les tirs et
l'aurait français même qu international
et puis elle était vraiment heureuse
alors récemment à la télévision on a dû
iggy pop dire qu'il aimerait bien
retrouver une femme et faire un enfant
et vous moi aussi a réussi un bien sûr
bien sûr mais je sais pas si c'est
facile ou encore parce que voilà j'ai 44
ans j'ai et je peux faire peur peut-être
mais bien sûr bien sûr je râle des sahwa
je suis
donc tout ça maintenant et terminé tu es
un mec bien je sais pas je suis pas si
c'est un mec bien j'essaye d'être moins
bon